[Musique]
abrina
abrina le fond des
Rivi c'est le Grand berceau
des amours dernièrement
rres importés par l'eau on Met dessus des
pont des pomes qui font peur Au fond des
rivi IL et un des
voyageurs Au fond des rives IL et à des
voyageurs partis fr
croisi pour des jours meilleurs sur Met
dessus de l'eau de l'eau
des couleurs qui font
rives des fluves
fleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
abrr
Rivi c'est le Grand départ vers les
estua nulle Part on Met dessus des ponts
des ponts tellement de précieux qu'au fond des
rivi nage dans le bleu Au fond des rivi
bovins IL et pas de
chanson si tu as des
mises à rentrer ta
Maison auras dessus un toit un toit et
qui dessus la
Rivi a Petit
voilier dessus
voilier
[Musique]
abrina
bouleau
avr
[Musique]
biru